a fundamental belief of the modern world
which explains a lot of our anxiety
around failure is that we are what we
earn when we say this we mean something
very particular not just that it's nice
to have a lot of money but that our
income is the source of information
crucial decisive information about our
character our intelligence our moral
fiber in short money is the key
indicator of our worth in human and not
just financial terms the more money we
make the more we deserve to exist by
extension it feels impossible to imagine
ourselves as good decent and still poor
but can all this really be true must we
hate and deem ourselves despicable
beings because our salary is not
elevated for an answer
we must look to economics and in
particular to the technical way that
salary is determined here we find
something striking wages are not decided
by the extent of someone's human worth
or social contribution per se wages are
simply the result of the intensity with
which certain people want a job done
relative to the number of people who
happen to be able to do it if many
people can complete a task however
humanly important it might be holding a
hand on a cancer ward for example little
money will be offered for it and if
there are very few people able to do it
however trivial it might be kicking up
all sixty meters into a goal if there's
intense demand salaries will be elevated
money is in fact no accurate measure of
the human worth of the work in question
the determinant of wages is just the
strength of demand in relation to supply
we may not be able easily to change how
much people earn but we can change how
we judge earnings this isn't an issue of
politics it's an issue of appreciation
we can change how we assess what a
modest wage mean
we can use our imaginations to remember
and hold in mind all that is not
quantified in a salary in our lives and
in those of others
all the degrees of intelligence care
dedication empathy and creativity that
may be present undetected by the blunt
aggregated marker of a wage however
tempting it might be to settle the
question of the value of human beings in
stark financial terms the truth remains
beautifully and redemptive ly more
complicated as we must realize as soon
as we've spent some time around a person
at work and got to know what site of
their character their Labor's will call
on through an average day will then have
no option but to reach a dauntingly
complex conclusion we are not what we
earn we publish new thought-provoking
films every week be sure to subscribe to
our Channel and take a look at more of
what we have to offer at the link on
your screen now